regi Aloysius Miller the hall-of-famer
one of the greatest three-point shooters
of all time reg on the call with Kevin
Harlan for the pelicans and the Blazers
that's Thursday night at 10:30 Eastern
good morning reg all right
greatest three-point shooter of all time
is you're asking me my opinion yes I've
said this many of times I'm still
throwing drazen petrovic as the greatest
three-point shooter that I've ever seen
but Steph is not slowly very
convincingly knocking down that wall of
being the greatest three-point shooter
and after what I saw last night I'm not
going to go off one performance but this
is a pattern that clay has put up just a
couple of years ago when he had the most
points and a half and went the zonkers
with nine dribbles scoring 50-something
points Stephon clay will go down as
arguably two of the greatest shooters to
ever play this game and the maddening
thing about it is that they're on the
same team and there's only one
basketball and you add Kevin Durant to
the mix and pretty soon boogie cousins
and they're still just successful so for
people saying all they've won
back-to-back they're gonna have a
championship hangover Steve Kerr and his
staff and the team I give them credit
they're finding ways to stay engaged and
when one of them gets hot it's almost
like a video game for them because they
feed off of that and they want to see
them succeed
Steph was just as excited getting his
NBA three-point record broken then I
think Clay was and I think that's what's
keeping this team engaged and once
boogie cousin comes back and he's seen
this on the bench I want to be a part of
this that's why no one's gonna be able
to touch this team barring major injury
yet they're playing against themselves
right now yeah should we move the
3-point shot back three-point line no no
the legal would become a gimmick if they
did that I mean in years past the
signature in basketball was what the
slam dunk yeah everyone wanted to be
like Mike your tongue was out your legs
were spread you were trying to jump from
the free
like dr. J the dunk was and at times can
be the most thrilling act in our game
but over the last seven to ten years 15
years it's been a three-point shot and
if you go to any local playground if
kids are still playing on the playground
or YMCA or gym or whatever kids aren't
trying to have their tongue out and you
know jump like Michael Jordan because
they can't but everyone can think they
can shoot like Steph Curry and his
pregame ritual and his dribbling and his
shooting from 25 35 45 feet everyone
thinks they can do that when they walk
into a gym the three-point line has
revolutionized what youth basketball is
now it's not the dunk
it's three-point people want to be like
Steph Curry like klay Thompson it's no
longer the high flyers it's all about
the shooters and amen
but what if I took out the 3-point shot
completely how would that with Golden
State be so much better than everybody
else without the 3-point line they're
not taking that I think Paulie would are
they 18th and three-pointers attempted
so far this season yes third and
efficiency the third best percent but
does that surprise you
they don't do vol Houston does vol the
golden say where you're still it doesn't
surprise me because I think they were
getting more efficient the older they
get remember analytics for Houston is
huge they want to beat you from three
free throws and layups whereas Kevin
Durant's game is instill mid-range it's
an old-school game and even though Klay
and Steph are very efficient and
high-volume three-point shooters that's
not really Katie's game now Katie could
knock him down for three obviously but
it's that mid-range game and getting to
the free-throw line that sets up
Durant's game so those numbers don't
surprise me they're not like Houston
where they're they're gonna live and die
by the three which caught up
last year's playoffs versus Golden State
they can beat you with Tuesday's well
it's not gonna Reggie Miller reg on the
call with Kevin Harlan pelicans and the
Trailblazers Thursday night at 10:30
Eastern on TNT the Lakers losing again
last night
you know as we talked about last week it
just feels like this is gonna be a
roller coaster ride Chris Mannix a Yahoo
Sports says this is a team that can't
figure out its identity should we be
asking the Lakers to know their identity
this many games into the season no again
and we've mentioned this let's be more
concerned come January first
if they're playing like this this yo-yo
type of we win a couple and then we lose
three or four their identity is wrapped
into LeBron James and he's gonna each
night he's you could book this 29 eight
and eight that's gonna be hit stat line
but he can't do it all so which one of
these young guns are going to emerge
Kuzma has had nights Ingram Ingram just
came back from the suspension and played
well last night but someone else is
gonna have to step step up for the ride
and again they have zero shooting and if
you go back and look at all of Ron James
successful teams they were he was
surrounded by shooters at the corners at
the edges big men who could stretch the
floor could open up the paint so he
could drive the Lakers don't have that
and they're gonna struggle in a
three-point shooting League where you
pack the paint
you're gonna dare people to shoot their
Darren Laker players to shoot and they
can't complete the job they're more
likely to not be with Golden State next
to your Kevin Durant or Klay time
listening to clays comments postgame you
know I think everyone saying I'll Clay's
gone he wants his own team it's time for
him to spread his wings
I think he's content but he wouldn't
have his own team I'm just not quite
sure there's enough dollars to pay
everyone and if they end up winning
again that's sarena role for Kevin
Durant
it pretty much cements I could see him
moving on but at the end of the day
isn't it all about I mean this team
could be like a Celtics dynasty if they
find a way to stick together but
someone's gonna have to take a pay cut
in clay already said he's not taking a
pick a hometown discount and Kevin
Durant shouldn't take a hometown
discount so I I I don't know there's not
enough money in the banks in in San
Francisco to pay all these guys so I
just don't see clay wanting to leave
because he's being spoon-fed right now
yeah we can go to the Lakers like
couldn't you see that situation where
the you know LeBron says look come in
and I got a bunch of passers here and
we're gonna make sure that you're you
know you're getting your shots I could
see that but to me I'll say it again
winning trumps everything and he started
the year 5 for 13 I know I know 3 no no
and goes crazy for 14 and there were
seven or eight and one with him
struggling like that why go somewhere
where the expectations would be much
higher
well right now you're playing behind
Steph Cady possibly boogie if he comes
back healthy and is the boogie that we
know remember it was a the top center in
the game before he went down so the
expectations would be higher if you went
to the Lakers why not chill have a latte
oh is it my turn tonight okay let me put
up 14 threes all right let me just chill
out until it's my turn it feels like
Durant would be the one to leave because
he will have cemented his legacy yeah
yeah and then he can have his own team
or whatever he wants to do and then oh
because you know what a lot of the
reaction was last night reg when Golden
State was killing Chicago was you know
what this is bad for basketball yeah
like we're not looking at those great
nights with Golden State you know it's
more of it it's a negative because you
know what look at what regimes yeah
super teams but that's the only way
you're gonna be the super team is
building another super team and what
players are going to commit to trying to
build that team I could see if Kevin
Durant wants to leave number one I would
leave the west
and I could see Madison Square Garden
with his name written all over he could
be the marquee guy in in New York a new
day
if porzingis comes back healthy they can
get possibly Kyrie and I mean they're
gonna need two guys to go to New York
with KD I could I could see that
happening a weaker conference but once
again at the end of the day I will
always trump winning and right now those
guys are there playing basketball versus
themselves
barring major injury no one will be able
to get a game possibly two off the
Warriors come playoff time if they're
all healthy
I mean Steph now is back to MVP step are
you kidding me man
are you kidding me this is crazy there
are times though you watching and you
forget that clay is on the team or you
forget the draymond Green is on the on
the team yeah usually we remembered
Ramon's on the team when it comes to the
postseason and then clay has these
nights like every you know five or six
nights where you go oh that's right that
guy the fact that he like catch and
shoot and which is amazing Reggie he had
the ball I think a little over 90 a
total of 90 seconds last night mm-hmm
it's just catch and shoot let's let's
revise your question when you ask the
best 3-point shooter of all time how
about the best catch and shoot
three-point shooter I I would arguably
put clay over stuff as a best catch and
shoot clay over to Ray Allen I might put
clay very good that's very good very
good
Ray is good catch I mean catch and shoot
but remember Ray was very good with the
balance to with the ball and handling so
different kind of catch and shoot is
clay better catch and shoot
three-point shooter than you I will
plead the fifth
okay I'm gonna you know what I'm gonna
do the Tom Brady clay is arguably one of
the greatest of all time and yeah I
would say clay I only do the Tom Brady
nominate yourself okay yeah Tom man I'd
love to see you today it's like like
Reggie at 28 in today's NBA game I've
had my time and I loved it don't do this
to me cuz then you gonna get me all
fired up and then I'm gonna write my my
mom who's in heaven and my dad who's in
Riverside I'm gonna write them on a
really nasty note for getting it on too
early okay all right so don't get me
going right my curse you saw and carry
man just imagine if you had like 15
minutes at work a night with the
Warriors red ball movement man movement
that's why did you see the excitement of
boogie cousins he gets thrown it you get
thrown out of the game in New York
and they they you know in the first
quarter and then the excitement I see on
his face on the bench like I am a part
of this team yeah the winning culture
that's all when he comes back he is
gonna run through brick walls for this
team because he saw the unselfishness
of when Steph went crazy versus
Washington through three quarters how
they were all spoon feeding him to get
him going and they saw last night when
clay got going every one setting screams
he wants to be a part of that that's why
it will work with him coming into this
system I was talking to the dance about
this when it comes to you know when Luca
Danxia came into the league everybody
talked about he didn't have a great
first step and I said I I'm not as
worried about your first step I want to
know what your last step is like and a
lot of guys off the dribble and I
mentioned Maravich and Jerry West we're
so good at that real hard last dribble
where you're already going up you know
you're gonna shoot and it's such an
advantage where that ball catches up
with you and that it to me it's always
underrated I don't know if they Scout
this but I look at Don Schick and look
at his last step more than his
first step it may not be fast but the
last step it feels like he he knows what
he's doing and he takes advantage of
that absolutely and and people you know
get caught up on speed and foot speed to
me it's all about footwork proper
mechanics and danke CH for a guy that's
19 years old so young has proper
footwork so a lot of times that trumps
people that are you know those little
speedy guys or you know first couple
dribbles because if you have proper
footwork you'll always be able to get
your shot off create space and have that
angle especially when you're driving
against the defender poly has got a
great three-point shooting question okay
Steph Curry is currently averaging 52
percent from three on the season only
four players in five four players in NBA
history have averaged 52% from three
none of them were starters they were all
bench guys like er Legler son bold Jason
Kapono
only one starter in NBA history guy
played like 70 starts average 50% or
more for the season from three can you
name him hence he's a foreign-born
player I will say what dirty one nope
that's a former teammate of yours reg
Holly I will go with Chris Mullin Detlef
Schrempf dad loose around 51% in k-cup
but he didn't take like he didn't shoot
the volume that's deaf though no correct
no but he was a starter he couldn't get
the ball away from you the hardest part
is true Wow
deadlift very home Wow Detlef was a very
good player and the original you know
when James Harden drives and he exposes
the ball where guys are always flapping
and is able to finish deadlift was the
first to create that move doesn't get
enough credit really the strong
fourarms I may have ever seen was great
in the post would expose the ball people
would try to swipe and strip it contact
n1 that lab strength have fun in your in
Portland right we are in Portland a good
game I hope do they love you how do they
treat you in Portland Portland is great
voodoo doughnuts yes doughnuts yum-yum
yes I love Portland Thank You reg safe
travels you are the best feet or dammit
you guys are on it on the three-point
shooting and elder all that today great
job guys thank you wrench
there you go reg with a compliment for
the Dennis there for more Dan Patrick
show to the audience Channel 239 on
Direct TV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]